it feels very shameful horrifying even
to admit but there are times when we may
find ourselves daydreaming about a
terrible thing happening to someone
close to us deep in the privacy of our
minds we may feel it would be a huge
relief if a partner or family member
could just vanish from the face of the
earth they might be run over at a
crossing the flame might go down they
could contract a rare and quickly fatal
illness it wouldn't need to hurt at all
it would be hugely sad of course but
also in certain ways an immense
liberation and relief no sooner has this
thought crossed our mind we're likely to
chase it out in horror and feel deeply
guilty about our depravity to put on
macabre imaginings into perspective the
first thing to remember is how little we
know
so what secretly goes through the minds
of other people we're aware of our own
darkest thoughts but rarely get to hear
those of others it's often the case
therefore that things will feel much
rarer to us than they are in reality it
turns out that grim imaginings are very
common counselors and therapists who get
to hear more of the hidden workings of
other people's minds than anyone else
but never surprised when a nice sensible
interesting client tentatively reveals
an occasional wish that a loved one
would be vaporized being close to
someone necessarily involves a high
degree of what therapists call
ambivalence a blending of deeply
negative and positive thoughts when
people play an outsize role in our lives
when they have an enormous emotional
power over us when our debt to them is
immense we will both adore and a points
resent them hugely it will be tenderness
and rage
attachment and revulsion they can let us
down like few others can they know our
weakest spots they enchant but also
exhaust us we're not actually going to
do anything of course we're not even
taking the tiniest for Pera Tory steps
we would never buy poison or encourage
them to go cliff walking on storming
evenings
there is relief to be found in the odd
grim daydream nevertheless fantasies are
not plans of action they don't
correspond to our real values or
intentions they operate as momentary
escapes from powerful feelings we
fantasize about the death of a loved one
not because we truly want them gone but
because being close to them is such a
large and therefore at times tricky part
of our lives our fantasy is a strange
but real tribute to the depth of a bond
the guilt is a symptom that despite the
inevitable and very real tensions and
disappointments of the relationship we
do care about them very much the meaning
of the fantasy isn't that with sick if
that loving someone is never free of
frustration fortunately it's highly
likely that our family member or partner
also harbors similar occasional
fantasies directed towards our and that
they too feel terribly ashamed and
guilty in exactly the way we do
this isn't monstrosity either just
further evidence but the beautiful and
surprising subtleties of love
you